hey guys it's Justine and today I'm
unboxing something really exciting I
just ordered this and it arrived very
quickly which I'm very excited about
because I really wanted what was inside
this box and it's crazy because this
isn't a new product but I thought it
would be really fun to just unbox it
show it to you see the types of things
that I'm getting during the lockdown who
would have thought that there was a
shortage of this product I don't know
[Applause]
you're greeted with a nice little
protective layer to protect your item
here it is because here it is we can
take a look this is the front of the box
and you'll see here that this lets you
know that you can make this in two and a
half minute cook time or here we have
all of our specs there's a hundred
milligrams of sodium 25 grams of carbs
and there's zero sugars that's a really
great selling point here is a very big
highlight on the spec sheet it says that
studies have shown that many Americans
do not consume enough calcium and here
we have some of the instructions nothing
new most products usually come with
instruction booklets but this one is
just very nicely marked here on the back
so you don't have to dig around on the
inside to try to find any loose paper
work I just appreciate how thorough they
are with everything that they have on
the back of here because they let you
know the best tips for results so when
you're preparing this with milk just
make sure that you watch carefully stir
to prevent the milk from boiling over
they also have a couple different models
of this this is the original I am a huge
fan of just simple basic but if you are
interested in other models maybe some
upgrades they have an instant brown
sugar they also have an instant variety
pack if you have whole grain and
cinnamon one of the things you should
always check for our expiration dates so
up here they nicely have that label
right here March third of 2022
impressive shelf life I mean you won't
have to worry about your product going
out of date for quite a while so this is
the on button you just have to press
here which i think is kind of misleading
because i'm pressing and it's not very
easy it's perforated not very well it's
possible a page of that for security
reasons I'm gonna make sense I was
really difficult I mean I had to
actually cut this open to get it all to
turn on to the smell test kind of smells
like a new Mac well now that we pretty
much have this all set up all opened all
unboxed I think that the next logical
step is to go test it out and see yeah
and see how it works okay
time has come to really give this a test
we're gonna follow the instructions oops
no gosh I've already not follow these so
shoot as old
[Music]
you don't really have to be that precise
about measurements I think it's gonna
catch on
[Music]
so I'm gonna be putting this in here to
really make sure we can maximize all of
the testing that we can possibly do
hi for one minute then we stir again and
then we continue the cook for an
additional one to two minutes Mikey wait
for breakfast tomorrow
[Music]
so one of the things that you need to
watch out for is you got to make sure it
doesn't boil over so this is kind of
just a midway little stir with a wire
whisk it didn't say how much to stir so
I'm using my own good judgment
[Music]
my mom always told me not to stand too
close to the microwave because it would
affect me my brain but I gotta keep an
eye on it because it's gonna overflow
this looks like a perfect consistency to
me do you think you can always add some
upgrades if you choose for my upgrade
today we're gonna be going with a
mountain forest raw honey and some
cinnamon that is labeled twice as
cinnamon this is probably an off-brand
generic which is totally cool as long as
it's compatible with your current device
you should be fine this honey just a
little and I think our upgrades complete
let's try it it's really hot oh my gosh
and this is great I definitely recommend
this version to everyone Horschel are
well thank you guys so much for watching
I know this probably is the first
unboxing that has been done of this
product I'm sure every other tech
reviewer has also unboxed this but I
just really wanted to kind of give my
take on it and show you what I got today
in the mail and I just really hope that
everyone is being safe and getting
enough girls to go so if some of you
guys are confused as to what's happening
on Twitter I was having this
conversation because I was looking for
cream of wheat and I couldn't find it
anywhere online I did want to go to the
store and the last time that I had one
in the store they didn't have any so I
just didn't know what to do so on
Twitter somebody said hey check Walmart
guess what Walmart had basically one box
and they said that it would get here by
Monday it actually arrived overnight
I had preached freaking FedEx to my
house from Walmart like that is at the
time that we're living in right now
everything is so weird
[Music]
I can't wait for breakfast tomorrow